angels versus venture we're going on to
our third slide here on a third topic
yeah so when we're looking at additional
sources of capital should a founder
focus on angels or VC firms venture
capital firms and what are the pluses
and minuses of them yes so I I think the
typically the way to decide who you
would focus on for a particular raise
would would be to start with how much
are you trying to raise so if the
typically we see if an amount is less
than you know a million dollars or so
that tends to lend itself more towards
angel investors that write smaller
checks and then over a million dollars
you typically find yourself and what
most people call institutional capital
which would be VC venture venture
capital and so thinking about kind of
the plusses and minuses about both of
them you know typically angels are going
to invest much faster make faster
decisions because they're there's only
one of them they don't have a there's no
team behind them that has to help make
that decision and then with VC's versus
angels one of the the pluses about
having a VC is typically they're going
to be more helpful that's not always the
case but an angel as often times has a
full-time job working at you know a
company perhaps running their own or
working for as a senior position in a
larger company and so the amount of time
that they can help with the perhaps the
amount of experience they have with the
with the specific startup is is less and
so is there a minimum check size you
should give because I get this question
a lot what are your thoughts on minimum
check sizes for angels and how to manage
that in let's say in this scenario
you're raising your $700,000 seed angel
round yeah what would you set the
minimum at and why yeah so why are there
minimums sure so cap table management is
is is really the factor here so as you
as your company progresses there's going
to be times where you need to collect
signatures
perhaps there's you know a large large
influx of a large capital raise that you
that you need to do to go back and get
permission from all of your smaller
investors on perhaps there's a date
a note or Saif was supposed to come due
and so you need to again get get get
that change and so you have to go back
and get signatures so in general you
want to try to keep the amount of folks
actually on your cap table to a minimum
and so that's typically why you would
ask for a minimum check and then it
depends you know I think the most common
number is probably around 50 K sometimes
as low as 25 K yeah and then as the
round increases you would typically see
that higher and then a lot of times the
question that founders will ask is how
valuable is this individual how much
what beyond the cash can they help with
the company and that typically helps
decide when they're not they earn their
spot on the on the cap table and
collecting signatures can be arduous
Ashleigh it certainly can yes
considering it's a large portion of what
you do is collect signatures for the
syndicate Mo's we're gonna get to later
but at this stage what are your thoughts
on seed funds versus venture funds
because this is also something that's
sort of a difference we have this new
emergence of 10 200 million-dollar funds
do they act quicker in our experience do
they have a different process than
venture funds
I mean diligence might be a little bit
less I mean it's still it's still formal
funding yeah it's I mean the checks I
sure is smaller but typically the fund
size overall is smaller so percentage is
probably fairly similar I don't know I
don't know if you have any thoughts on
it yeah it's you know you would think
that as with a smaller fund that the
decision and the diligence decision
would be faster diligence would be less
it doesn't seem to be that common
actually it seems like the processes
seem pretty similar the amount of time
it takes to make a decision seems pretty
similar we've had a number of companies
that have recently kind of gone both
routes and it seems like those decisions
and processes are pretty similar not
unfortunate that you know we would hope
that some more nimble and smaller would
be able to act faster but doesn't seem
to be the case actually very much yeah
have you seen I would say seed funds
tend to have two or three partners
whereas a venture firm might have double
that or triple it they might have six
and so I have seen seed funds me
be able to act a little quicker because
if you only have to you know if satya
and hunter hunter from homebrew just
picking an example of us I think they
were 60 million often there might be 120
now I think they may have added one or
two more partners but in the early days
maybe they could just write a check very
quickly because they just have to text
each other or make one phone call to
each other say hey you cool with this or
not as opposed to the Monday morning
meeting had a seed fund or a venture
fund where you have to sort of build
consensus and then picking VCS to target
how do we advise people to pick people
to target you know who should I get an
introduction to who should I try to
pitch my business to I mean taking a
look at their portfolio is a great start
I think just getting to know it I mean
it's hard to get to know someone on
social but sort of following different
VCS and getting to know how they operate
I mean you're gonna be in business with
this person for quite some time so you
have to like the person you have to want
to be in business with them and vice
versa yeah of course of course I mean
Demond deals with his a lot more than I
do since he's went during his pipeline
and I'm getting feedback from founders
but yeah I think the Ashley's point
looking at the portfolio seeing that
they have an interest in your space but
have not invested in a competitor as
typically kind of the first the first
part okay so they are interested let's
say I had an app that was a consumer app
and it was for mindfulness or something
meditation mindfulness journaling
whatever so in this case what would I
look for in a venture firm for let's
call it like my calm calm competitor yep
so first make sure that they haven't
invested in a calm or a headspace or one
of something that the question that I
would typically ask a founder when
they're looking at looking at a
portfolio is if the reverse situation
happened if they'd invested in you first
and then the VC came to them and asked
can we invest in this company how would
you feel about that right and if you
wouldn't feel comfortable then the
reverse
the reverse doesn't make sense right so
they've invested in headspace or calm
you're likely not to invest in you so
you can kind of eliminate them from the
pool yeah but let's say they've invested
in maybe some sort of exercise okay sure
company so that clearly says that you
know they're into let's say wellness as
a general category they invest in
peloton or the class pass yep yep two
good examples but they don't have kind
of the the the president's the
meditation app that would that would be
a good example of they're clearly
interested in the general space and so
potentially a good target for for this
particular app for okay are we gonna go
to syndicates later in the deck or
should we address that now we can dress
it now let's address it now syndicates
because this is something that we do at
Jason syndicate comm and we've done 96
of those and Ashley or the managing
director of the syndicate let's do aside
from putting angels aside right now and
just say venture capital slash seed
funds versus a syndicate how are they
different so they're they're different
in that the amount can be flexible we're
not typically as a syndicate we're not
typically looking for the you know
setting the terms and looking for that
same target ownership as VC would but we
and sort of back to the montz point
about angels maybe not being as helpful
because they have full-time jobs a
syndicate is you know up to 250
accredited investors that maybe they
have full-time jobs also and they most
of them do but there's 250 of them right
and so we're not just investing funds
you know we're not investing anywhere
from 100k to 2.4 million just to be on
the cap table we're also super charging
that investment with a bunch of really
knowledgeable credit investors who will
help with marketing for the company our
customers will help with hiring you know
just have different expertise that they
can share with the founders and I mean
not to knock a seed fund or a VC but
they don't typically have that volume
they have they have a significant
network but they don't have the you know
that volume of
you know 250 people that are not just
financially invested in the company but
are really truly interested they're
opting in to invest in this we're not
you know we don't make anyone we don't
set a minimum number of deals they have
to invest in per year they get to invest
only in what they're extremely excited
about and if you had what's the average
number of participants what would the
median be because I know just off the
time I had we had a couple that got into
that 250 range 200 range and then I've
seen as low as 50 or 60 what's our
median would you say 80 so you have 80
people now does this mean I've got to
chase 80 signatures that's a great
question Jason no you do not have to
chase 80 signatures that's a great
that's a great point so you have all
this power behind and and you know brain
power behind it but you only need one
signature and that signatures of the
lead of the syndicate in our case it's
mainly Jason yes but it's so yeah you
don't you don't have to chase all these
investors to approve a new round to
improve to approve an increase in shares
- you know when you go to do your you
know pro-rata round it's not everyone
opting in all at once it's saying you
know the lead saying yes we want to do
this or no we don't you don't have to
get general consensus consensus so one
item on the cap table and item on the
cap table but 80 participants mm-hmm how
do if you complete a syndicate at least
with our syndicate how does the founder
tap in to those 80 people do they get
their email addresses do they have to do
a phone call with all 80 to raise money
just let's do a little bit of mechanics
there yeah so to meet them you know we
we being launched we work with the
founder to create a deal memo that
really you know describes their their
company in a sort of basic way and then
we give a link to a webinar so when we
send that that deal memo out it's just
quick you know trailer of their company
and then if that's of interest the
investors can then attend the webinar or
even reach out to the founder directly
and get more questions answered to do
their own sort of due diligence get
their take on the health of the company
and then once you know so of course if
the investor reaches out directly to the
founder that way they have their contact
information but at that time
that investor really is opted into
sharing that information by reaching out
yeah if we once we close the deal of
those 80 investors who opted in we don't
we keep them anonymous unless they want
to want to not be so what in the way we
do that is we just include them on one
group one you know a listserv that the
founder then adds their update list and
if they want to respond when the founder
sends out update they can we always
recommend that a founder immediately
after closing sends a welcome letter to
all the syndicate members saying thank
you so much for investing this is a
little bit of more background about my
company you know hey introduce yourself
is there anything you can help us with
this is you know this is we're hiring or
this is what we need help with and the
investors who want to be known and want
to be helpful we'll reach out at that
point but there's absolutely no
obligation to do so and you can do it
passively if that's you know sort of
your investment thesis the interesting
things that I'd never anticipated when
we started syndicating five years ago
was the comm deal the first one in
almost five years ago that's five years
ago we did calm calm our first deal
which is 17th April 17th oh wow right
around the corner after have a party and
obviously that was a five million dollar
valuation and the company recently
announced a billion dollar valuation so
it's the most successful syndicate done
in the history of syndicates whether
it's seedinvest Republic AngelList or
funders club or any of them one of the
things I never anticipated was that a
syndicate member might put 50k into a
deal or 25k into a deal and then
eventually then lead the next round and
we had that happen with one company
which was a cannabis company cush
marketplace where one of our syndicate
members maybe made a small check or a
medium sized check and then said you
know I love this company so much I'm
spending time with them would it be okay
if we led the next round
and we said yeah I think that's okay and
so I always encourage people when
they're dealing with accredited
investors to understand that they might
only be putting in a 2k or a 5k or 10k
check from you know syndicate whether
it's on AngelList or ours but they then
might in a future round add a zero or
two to that number or three because
they're accredited
you